pensemos acerca de cómo descomponer
problemas de sumas ya que esto es útil
porque si sabemos cómo descomponer bien
este tipo de problemas nos va a
facilitar hacer el cálculo de la suma
veamos este primer problema laura no
está segura sobre cómo sumar 3961 ayuda
a la hora a elegir un problema con sumas
que sea lo mismo que 3961 y tenemos
estas opciones los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de resolver esto por
su cuenta
resolvamos los juntos veamos esta
primera opción de dónde viene este 30
bueno este 30 son tres decenas y
efectivamente aquí tenemos tres decenas
este tres en el 39 está en la posición
de las decenas por lo que representa 30
ahora veamos de dónde sale este 60 bueno
en el número 61 el 6 está en la posición
de las decenas por lo que representa
seis decenas o sesenta luego sigue el 90
de donde vendría este 90 bueno aquí no
veo ningún
9 en la posición de las escenas
podríamos verlos tentados a decir bueno
aquí veo un 9 pero este 9 está en la
posición de las unidades no de las
decenas así que esto es un 9 no un 90 y
aquí tengo un 1 que no es un 90 y
tampoco es un 10 si en lugar de tener un
90 estuviera un 9 y en lugar de tener el
día estuviera un 1 una unidad entonces
esto tendría sentido 30 60 91 pero no 30
más 60 más 90 más 10 así que esta no es
la opción correcta veamos la siguiente
esto tiene sentido porque tenemos aquí
el 30 más en 9 nos dan 39 y el 60 más el
1 nos van a dar el 61 así que estas dos
cosas son equivalentes y la razón por la
que es útil descomponer estas sumas de
esta forma es porque nos es más fácil
calcular las 30 más 60 es tres decenas
más seis decenas lo que es igual a
noventa
9 1 es igual a 10 y 90 + 10 es igual a
100 no nos han pedido que hagamos la
suma simplemente nos preguntan cuál de
estas opciones es equivalente a esta
suma y esta es la opción correcta sólo
podemos elegir una opción y esta es la
adecuada pero veamos por qué esta no es
tenemos el 91 pero aquí tenemos 3 más 6
este 3 de aquí no sólo representa a un 3
por la posición en donde se encuentra
representa a 3 decenas que es 30 así que
esto debería ser 30 y este 6
lo vemos aquí pero de igual forma por la
posición en donde se encuentra este 6 no
representa a un 6 sino a 6 decenas o lo
que es lo mismo 60 pero no es lo que
escribieron aquí así que esta opción no
es correcta hagamos otro problema que
suma es la misma que 41 57 y vemos que
las opciones de aquí ya las tenemos
descompuestas en decenas y unidades
así que antes de ver estas opciones
vamos a descomponer esto de la misma
forma veamos el 41 en la posición de las
escenas tenemos un 4 así que tenemos 4
decenas y en la posición de las unidades
tengo un 1 así que es una unidad esto es
para el 41
ahora para el 57 en la posición de las
decenas tenemos al 5 así que aquí
tenemos cinco decenas cinco decenas y en
la posición de las unidades tenemos un 7
más 7 unidades ahora sí veamos cuál de
estas opciones es igual a lo que
acabamos de escribir aquí esta primera
opción tenemos cuatro decenas y una
unidad que coinciden con las que tenemos
aquí estas cuatro decenas más esta
unidad va a ser igual a 41
y también tengo cinco decenas cinco
decenas y siete unidades siete unidades
cinco decenas y siete unidades así que
esta primera opción es la correcta
simplemente se encuentran las cosas en
otro orden si yo hubiera escrito cuatro
decenas más cinco decenas más una unidad
más siete unidades sería exactamente
igual a esta opción de aquí y con esto
habríamos terminado pero vamos a ver las
demás opciones para darnos cuenta de qué
es lo que no coincide en esta opción
vemos las cuatro decenas que sabemos de
dónde vienen pero después tenemos una
decena y bueno aquí pareciera que este
uno quisieron ponerlo como decena pero
el una está en la posición de las
unidades así que va a ser una unidad no
una decena lo que está equivocado y
además nos dicen aquí que hay cinco
unidades y el único cinco que tenemos
está en la posición de las decenas aquí
en el 57 por lo que
esta opción es incorrecta ahora la
siguiente nos dicen cuatro unidades pero
aquí el único cuatro que tenemos esta es
la posición de las escenas así que este
4 representa a un 44 de escenas y luego
nos dicen 5 unidades y el único 5 que
tenemos nuevamente está en la posición
de las escenas son 5 de escenas 50 15
unidades así que éstas deberían ser
decenas de escenas lo que hace que
confirmemos que esta es la opción
correcta